[Music]
over the last few decades have been
extraordinary ventures in how we can
study the brain and when it's some of
the most exciting are those that enable
us to study the brain in waking
conscious subjects and I suppose the
most exciting for me as somebody who was
in neuroscience for many years it's
functional magnetic resonance imaging in
which you can actually indirectly see
the neural activity of the brain in
waking subjects in all sorts of
circumstances so for many people this is
seemed to give us a window onto the mind
my own position is it tells us an awful
lot about the brain and it's very useful
particularly those who like me are
concerned about new methods of treating
brain disease but it tells us very
little about the nature of the mind of
the interesting things about the human
mind for example it may tell us a little
bit about sensation possibly about
perception but nothing about wisdom love
aesthetic sense or generally have a
shakedown with each other in everyday
life one of the dreams is that a result
of using these new techniques or their
successors we will find ways in which
the human mind works let's have a
thought experiment let's supposing we
had a technique that enabled us to look
at every single activity of every single
neurone in the brain and we were able to
identify how all the neurons were wired
together and let us suppose also we
could follow people say somebody was in
love for three months more as a result
of this technique learn would we learn
and think more about love then we
learned from poetry from our daily
experience from music from philosophy
and I don't think so
because what would be the output of this
machine lots and lots of zeros and ones
which would hardly illuminate the nature
of love one of those tinting questions
is whether by looking the brain we can
solve the hard bomb problem of
consciousness basically the problem of
how it is that it is like to be
something and I don't think we will when
we look at the brain we look at it as an
object of course we do we are
viewers of the brain we're looking at
the it ease of the brain and in looking
at the eighties of the brain it gives us
very little insight into the I am of the
person of the subject and you may say
well that's okay sort of technical
interests but actually behind it is
something much bigger which is our
nature as human beings
my feeling is I'm a secular humanist my
feeling is that yes we've parked up
religion some of us have but it doesn't
mean to say that the alternative
religion is a naturalistic account of
what we are that we are essentially
identified with ourselves as organisms
or the or the evolved organ that is the
human brain I don't think that's the
alternative I think there's another
alternative which is we are human beings
who are neither Apes nor angels and
those who are basically want to identify
ourselves with our evolved brains I
think secretly imagine that we are
somehow Apes and I don't think that is
the case and by the way we are unique in
least one respect let us say we exercise
our self over our own nature which I
don't think Apes do a lot of people said
well okay in separating the brain from
the mind or distinguishing the brain
from mind you'll suggest that we are
something elusive spiritual not to be
understood as it were as part of the
world
well my way of separating the brain from
the mind is not in a Cartesian sense of
seeing us as kind of ghosts in the brain
machine I think we are certainly
conscious beings and courtesy of our
brains we are conscious basically you
get rid of my brain you get rid of my
consciousness chop my head off my IQ
falls and so on and so forth but that
doesn't mean to say that I believe as it
were there are two substances one is
mental the mind or there is physical the
brain I don't think we've even got the
beginning of understanding where our
consciousness fits in to the larger
universe the universe of which we are
conscious the universe which we've
actually called the universe the
universe we put in inverted commas we
haven't been begun and I don't think we
begin until we Park up a whole part of
bankrupt theories one is materialism the
idea that the mind is essentially the
proper property of the brain or
identical with neural activity
the other is dualism the notion that
there's a ghost of the mind in the
machine of the brain
the third is Pan psychism the idea that
mine must be everywhere otherwise we
couldn't have it in the brain I think
all of those are utterly bankrupt
theories I am an ontological agnostic I
do not know how we relate mind and body
and indeed how many fundamental kinds of
things there are
but until we recognize we haven't the
faintest idea at the moment we won't
even begin and I'm totally one with
Jerry Fodor the great psychologist who
said that we will make no progress in
understanding relationship between mind
and brain until we set aside many many
assumptions concepts and cherished ideas
and I think that's what we need to do
and then we can really start the moment
we're not even at the beginning do we
have any theories about consciousness we
have lots and lots of daft there is and
I could bore you stiff by reciting some
of the bonkers theories there are I
don't think we need to we are need to
have a theory of consciousness nor we
are likely to arrive at because after
all a theory is a late product of
consciousness and to have a theory of
consciousness that explains conscious is
like the roof of the house somehow
explaining the foundations and I don't
think that it's possible we can do many
other useful and interesting things
quite separate from having a theory of
consciousness and with in neuroscience
neuroscience has potentially great use
in helping us to address particularly in
my case of interest address brain brain
disease and so on and so forth but the
idea of having a theory of consciousness
would be more than a theory of
everything it will be a theory of that
which is able to produce theories of
everything all claims to I have been to
the festival years ago in the early days
when it was just starting including the
winter festivals as well and I've always
been impressed by the sheer quality of
the dialogue the discussion
unlike many literary festivals this is
not literary Fester it's festive ideas
it isn't sort of celebrity based it's
based really on ideas really on
discussion and I have to say it's a
feast for the mind and so things I've
enjoyed today I had to absolutely drag
myself out reluctantly on
the debate on the Big Bang and the
creation of the universe I had to get
out because I had to give my own gig to
be honest I would have preferred to
estate and listen to what Sean Carroll
and Roger Penrose and people that had to
say it was an extraordinarily wonderful
discussion for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
institute of arts and ideas at iai TV
you